man it's been a while pal it's good to  see you hey i guess we can take these  things off huh totally absolutely before  i before i do there's something i i  haven't been totally upfront about with  you what are you talking about i i don't  i don't really know how to put it you're  making me nervous i don't don't don't  get don't get mad okay  it's just that i happen to want to grow  it and happen to be wearing masks all  the time so you've had this mustache the  whole time okay look it wasn't no no no  excuses please i can every time i think  of our memories together i have to like  change them in my head to imagine you ha  with a mustache i know i i get i mean  what is it  please please i don't feel safe around  you anymore okay all right look i know  i'm overreacting i just i have something  to show you  myself oh  we're mustache buddies i feel like a lot  of guys did this right come on give it a  little smooch  [Music]  normalize kissing your friend's mustache